[Applause]
great trap and rotation herder under
duress spoke donovan
for three oh killer and he says
shush to the crowd
this is a great save here now once they
go on the trap
there it is that was a tough shot
because it was a pickup
it wasn't a direct pass and he was able
to make the three
now in this game it wasn't a direct pass
and he was able to make the three now in
this game
they throw it into the backcourt for
trey young
[Applause]
their surest ball handler throws it up
and that is
the exclamation point john collins with
that smoke
to say good night the pass i'll just
watch as they come in there
see he embiid was right there now
has to get it in bounds here you can run
the baseline after a made basket of
bodonovich
double-team oh crap with the layup
and it's a three two point game this has
been a great move by the philadelphia
coaching staff
time and time again they've been able to
out muscle them
and you know in the back court 10 feet
from the baseline
the double team has been great the
deflections